hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the end of us now this
has nothing to do with the Last of Us it
was actually made before the Last of Us
even came out and it was made for a game
Jim and it was recommended because it's
supposed to be emotional and happy and
sad at the same time now I have no idea
what that means but it was recommended
by you guys so I'm gonna give it a try
hello oh ok pretty music what am i doing
I wasn't sure what I was at first but it
seems I'm a comment floating through
space I hope I don't crash into anything
filled with life and very close oh hi
how's it going for you oh I see we're in
a little bit of a dance eh oh it's like
Ken and yang ah I'm coming to get you
I'm gonna get you get you get you come
back you almost so far there's really
interesting you never know what to
expect when you come out of these game
jam games and there is the gamejolt
game jam featuring me jacksepticeye and
I believe PewDiePie and they're making
up some games over there it already
started I believe but you guys can still
check it out and see what games are
being made right now hello I seem to be
able to thump into this guy I don't know
if this is a meteors version of flirting
or what I blow hey okay woah are we
going through a nebula I mean obviously
we're floating through space but I'm not
sure why
Oh where we go oh hey one thumb hey I
like you you're cool
wanna go on a date sometime oh I'm not
sure whether it's leading the funk funk
Slater is later on in the day oh hey oh
cool
dammit okay
hey hey those are mine hey hey hey come
on now hey hey hey hey hey hey maybe we
got to work together to get them no now
I feel like we're actually competing hey
get out here my stars my stars mine mine
oh my what in it no idea where that
won't you tear didn't mean the AI in
this one common is better than the AI in
many games that I've ever played
no no dammit I can't oh man I'm so bad
at this well I
this really harder to control than it
seems I mean you guys might be looking
at the stars mark would know it's it's
it's it's it it's inconsistent like it's
kind of that elastic controls so that
the amount that I put it's hard okay
I'm not gonna try to explain why I'm
doing this actually I shouldn't have to
explain why I'm doing badly I should
just say my name and you'd be like oh
okay
he's gonna play bad I understand all
right okay we're done with that
I can stop embarrassing myself and
justifying my actions bonk bonk boom
big bug Oh are we bigger now we kind of
faded a little bit what what does that
mean why is that why is that what is
that what's that hit him anymore oh we
might break no no no me I'll protect you
I shall protect you ha ha ow my face ok
now we're both equally broken Oh No
oh I'll save you oh no that's that's not
saving anybody oh crap what do we do oh
crap oh poor India India's about to get
it oh boy here we go
what happened
would happen kamu what happened it's
really pretty like I'm playing through
it again to try to catch some more
meaning out of it it's really pretty
because I was just sitting here like
dancing around the other one just going
to be going to do point you do going to
do point and I do notice that it is in
time with the music you can have as many
stars as you want cuz I can't get them
that's obvious we're getting them
together
we're being togetherness oh you're
giving me a chance you're so cool you're
catching the ones I miss oh that's much
better than how I was going last time ow
ow okay your turn I guess oh I guess
when I stop being greedy more the stars
got got anyway and it was a little bit
better for everyone involved
Wow Wow we could have just dodged it but
thanks for taking the brunt of that
anyway I wonder if there's a way for me
not to get hit I mean be really dude oh
no I don't know no no not me
aw crap well that happens it won't even
let me not be the old maybe will oh my
god I didn't know that it could
what's gonna happen then what's gonna
happen then it is different
oh I'm dancing alone I'm dancing alone
looks so sad all now the dust is orange
oh no I can't move it anymore dancing
alone so there's no point in dancing so
the comment kind of slows down and gives
up I I think the message is like because
it was supposed to represent in a very
basic way two things coming together and
then being very competitive and butting
heads and then working together and then
cooperating and then one sacrificing for
the other that was really really
interesting even though I Madison what
the other kind of just plowed right
through earth earth exploded everything
died but that was really sad but happy a
good because I guess they were old at
that point so it was like two comments
that spent their entire lives together
and they got damaged and protected each
other and grew together and like danced
together and even though they butted
every once in a while they they work
together that was really sweet I can see
I see now because I didn't catch it on
my first playthru I didn't fully
understand it product as it was talking
out my butt but that was really
interesting it's a really simple message
expressed in a really creative way I
like it this game is really cool for
being a 48-hour game DM game this games
pretty cool
so thank you Chelsea how and Michael
Molinari for making the game if you guys
want to check it out you can check the
link in the description below let me
know what you think of this game because
I might be wrong in my interpretation
but let me know what you think in the
comments stem
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye